hello emilio how are you i'm well carlos
how are you today
doing very good you know as a kid of the
90s it's it's really fun even just to
say the name
coach bombay and know that it's like
happening right now like that's pretty
cool what compelled you to come back
well you know if you look at sort of the
trajectory of for the last
25 years i kind of exited mainstream
uh filmmaking with the mighty ducks
three and i feel like this is using the
um
the the the mighty ducks game changers
as a re-entry vehicle
in into more mainstream uh affair
um you know the world of independent
filmmaking is is a tough one
uh you often struggle to for people to
see your work
and um so i thought you know after the
last 25 years
uh that it was it was time to sort of
re-engage
and and get busy again and you know get
out of the um
self-imposed wilderness that i've been
in in the independent film world
um having said that i had great uh
experiences
on the in the independent film world i
had four of the films that i
directed ended up being the toronto film
festival premieres so so i'm grateful
for that experience but i'm really
excited about returning
now to play coach bombay and uh once
again
and um and and sort of reconnect
to not only uh people of a certain age
but also their kids
yes and coach bombay goes on a somewhat
of a parallel journey here as well you
know when we
catch up with him uh what can you tell
us about what he's been through and
where his head's at now
well it's interesting he's he's he's
kind of a shadowy figure
uh in in the in the new iteration of
of the franchise uh he's hiding out
he's um you know basically living in his
office he lives at the skating rink
that he's inherited from uh from his old
mentor
and um he's he's eating leftover
birthday cake and leftover pizza from
from kids birthday parties at the ice
rink and
he's not really engaged and through
the course of lauren graham's character
alex
uh asking if she can uh you know be
there
with the team and and and have a place
for them to train
he has pulled out of his shell over the
course of the uh
of the ten episode uh series so it was
interesting to
kind of play this guy who the last time
we saw him was sort of top of his game
and you know it's this lawyer and this
you know revered coach
to now being this kind of a bit of a
troll
right honestly right living you know i i
i
under um you know basically sleeping on
his office couch
yeah the the original series of movies
were
like you know game changers in so many
ways
right um how important was it for you
to come on board to this project having
it carry the same sort of spirit because
it really does seem like it does
well for for me it was really about um
uh were we going to recapture
the magic of the first three films
because you know obviously we're we are
kind of at peak nostalgia
right now uh we ever every time you seem
to turn on a tv
there's a reboot or a reimagining of an
old
piece of ip uh what i wanted to make
sure with
with the mighty ducks is that we weren't
just going back to work and re
branding it for that reason that we
could recapture and we could
reconnect and we would do all the things
that
um that to remind audiences why people
fell in love with
with the films and with the character in
the first place and i think that we've
done that i mean
it's you know obviously we have five
hours or ten episodes
in which to tell the story which is a
luxury uh considering you know
with a film you have an hour and a half
two hours to to uh to tell your entire
story so
we have a long well a long period of
time in which to sort of peel
the onion of these these characters back
yeah
it's it's honestly really good to see
you back you know um
we saw you at tiff thank you for the
public and that was great it's awesome
well
because i want to know you said you're
coming back to mainstream stuff like
what do you have planned what's in the
pipeline
well uh you know there's uh obviously
this um
there there have been rumors about a
young guns three uh
reboot speaking of reboots so we're uh
i'm i'm excited to to to get back uh
into that character and play that role
put my guns back on and
and my boots and get back on a horse um
certainly i'm excited i'm excited for
that um so right now that's sort of in
in the future and
and um and hopefully we'll we'll be able
to get that up and running soon
that's awesome man well i can't wait for
all of that like that sounds super cool
to me thank you so much for your time
carlos thanks so much man have a great
day